August seventh last year ms benazir
bhutto came to Yale University and sat
down with me at this studio to discuss
the state of affairs in her country she
told me why she wanted to go back home
she said it was not for herself but to
save as she put it saved my country from
destruction and disintegration on
December 27th last year she was
assassinated just after she had
delivered a speech condemning extremism
in the interview she gave to me on our
seventh last year she said we want an
end to the attacks on NATO and Afghan
forces in nearby organizar marry
militants and we want an end to the
militants who tried to hijack our
foreign policy by conducting attacks on
indian parliament and on other sites in
india so our world vision collides other
dramatically with the world vision of
the exhibits how true she was
we are pleased to have in our studios
mrs. benazir bhutto two x prime minister
pakistan and we are actively pleased to
have her with us today at the time of
pakistan is facing a critical choice
about its future welcome this is bhutto
Thank You mr. Nanda it's lovely to be at
here thank you politics is as far
removed from porch as possible so I
cannot resist reading little poem that
you wrote some years ago one has might
the other right one has soared the other
depend guns rust and fall apart ideas
live forever so do you think President
Musharraf's guns are rusting and that is
why he's turning to you to do idiom
certainly there has been a degree of
unease within Pakistan General Musharraf
had given a charter of where he wanted
to take the country which was towards a
true democracy and a moderate society
however in the last six years we've seen
that the extremists have spread
throughout the country and we used to
think it was just in the tribal areas
but indeed the red mosque incident in
our capital city of Islamabad showed
that the tentacles of extremism was
spreading and that poses grave
challenges to Pakistan from within as
well as complicates the external picture
so the reason why he is now willing to
sit down with you is because he's
feeling that he is no longer in full
control I see it differently I think
after nine eleven when the first general
elections were held under General
Musharraf it was less than a year later
and he was seen very much as a strong
ally of the West on which the
international community could depend to
reform the madrasas and to constrain and
restrain the terrorist elements within
the country but unfortunately since then
there has been the rise of suicide
bombings innocent people in Pakistan
like our women and children
are being killed and I think not the
international community has started
supporting the democratic process within
Pakistan we've had a pro-democracy
movement which has gathered strength as
poverty in the country increased and
people's needs were neglected so this
confluence has made the elections of
2007 very important all the independent
polls show that the pakistan peoples
party and i would go on to win any fair
election so i think that this is what is
the need of drawing people together in
pakistan we have different fault lines
we have one on dictatorship versus
democracy and we have a second one on
moderation versus fundamentalism more
extremism so I think the general
musharraf is trying to seek away out by
having these contacts with the pakistan
peoples party mm-hmm the North Sharif
has suggested that one should do
everything to remove military from
politics and what you may be trying to
do it would be seen by people as per
awning the military rule rather than
getting rid of military altogether I
know that's what mr. Nawaz Sharif was
saying but I don't agree and I find it
very strange to mr. Nawaz Sharif talk to
general musharraf and got out in the
year 2000 which did prolong military
rule in my country I was also offered
that I will if I quit politics for 10
years all the charges against me would
be dropped and my husband would be
released but I refuse that offer because
I felt that it would prolong military
rule in my country and now I'm talking
because this is about getting the
uniform out of the office of the
presidency this is about facilitating
the transfer to democracy and as I said
we are talking but we are not there yet
so I'm really not in a position to tell
you today that they really will be in a
an agreement on the facilitator transfer
to democracy but I do know one thing
that a facilitator transferred to
democracy is far more preferable than a
situation of chaos on the streets that
can be taken advantage of
by extremist elements so as a Pakistani
leader who wants to see the stability
and unity of my country and see Pakistan
go on the path of moderation I think
it's important for me to explore bees
full political options of a transfer to
democracy I will point out to you that
no one believed when the Shah of Iran
was facing street riots that it would
end up in an Ayatollah revolution but
that's what happened and when the
mensheviks took to the streets against
in Russia no one expected the Bolsheviks
so you know when we have a situation
where we have militants who are armed
and we have political parties who are
unarmed I would do my best to have a
peaceful transfer but if that fails
maybe I won't be able to stop the street
agitation and that would be dangerous so
let's hope that we can indeed get either
through the negotiations we are having
all through the Supreme Court of
Pakistan some kind of a facilitated and
peaceful revival of the Constitution
restoration of the democratic process
and a redress of people's social and
economic needs so that terrorism and
militancy can be undermined according to
some Press reports that the agreement
that has been reached between you and
President Musharraf i prime is that he
will be a civilian president while you
will be a as a simulant president will
be in charge of national security and
foreign affairs and you will be chief
executive and the ban on you as running
Prime Minister for third time will it
lifted and your family can return is
there any truth in this these are
certainly some of the issues that are
being discussed General Musharraf wants
to get elected from the present
assemblies he thinks that's legal we in
the PPP believe that it's not legal so
this mat is going to be decided really
by the courts and perhaps by public
pressure do but ultimately it's a
decision of a legal dispute
the elections are going to be held later
this year my concern is that those
elections should be fair free and
impartial I believe that military I
believe with the International Crisis
Group that military intervention in the
country is creating a failed state which
poses a danger to Pakistan's own
security as well as regional security so
I'd like those elections to be fair and
I think any attempt by General Musharraf
to manipulate those connections will
lead to a far bigger internal crisis
with far-reaching repercussions we
haven't reached an agreement yet because
everything the regime says it will do is
post presidential prime ministerial and
parliamentary elections and my party
doesn't want to be led up the garden
path so we believe that the cooperation
needs to be calibrated so that there are
different phases of implementation there
a is it possible that if he gets
reelected by the Parliament one more
time but he makes you the interim Prime
Minister so that there can be free and
fair election in December do you accept
that no no no no I'm not looking at this
for myself I'm looking at this for the
empowerment of my people and I'm looking
at this for saving my country from a
militant take oh well god forbid
disintegration I think it's the worst
crisis that we faced since 1971 what we
are looking for is a cooperation once
the uniform is off the PPP cannot
cooperate with a uniform presidency
which blurs the distinction between
civil and military rule because the PPP
has been fighting every single military
dictatorship that there has been in the
country and we symbolize the aspirations
of the people for a democratic Pakistan
the PPP is also looking for the holding
of fair elections we want like a
situation where the elections are
manipulated and then we are offered a
handful of ministries in return for
legitimizing a fraudulent election so
what what would be necessary for you to
consider the election will be
here and free what would be the
condition very good question very good
question the all parties conference held
in July earlier this year which was
hosted which was called for by the
Alliance for the restoration of
democracy came up with the points that
need to be implemented by the Election
Commission of Pakistan for the holding
of fair elections and earlier the very
widely respected international group
known as the NDI the National Democratic
Institute held a roundtable of all
political parties in Pakistan and the
round table also came up with proposals
and we have handed these proposals over
to General Musharraf side and they have
been promising us for some months that
they will actually implement various
proposals that have come during the time
for fair elections that they keep
reassuring us that the elections will be
fair but unfortunately except for
transparent ballot boxes none of those
reforms have been implemented which is
really leading to some unease in the PPP
circles and indeed the opposition
circles that now the elections around
the corner when is this all going to
happen when are these reforms going to
be lifted then there is also the issue
of a balance between the presidency and
the Parliament I see little point in
getting a parliament elected where the
Prime Minister's thrown out two months
later I mean we had this in the 90s
where the presidential power to dismiss
Parliament's was used ruthlessly not
only against mr. Nawaz Sharif and myself
twice but even against mr. Junaid oh so
we feel that there's little point taking
our country backwards to the instability
of the 90s we have to move forward
towards a better political system where
we know what the role and responsibility
of the Parliament is and what the role
and responsibility of the President is
how does one reach that without a
constitutional reform well General
Musharraf assures us that he wants
Parliament to have all the powers and he
says he doesn't want any powers himself
but there's a dichotomy because the
Constitution actually gives all the key
powers to the presidency so this is an
issue on which the discussions are still
ongoing because while gentleman sheriff
says he wants all parts to be with the
Parliament he seems unwilling to give up
the presidential power
to dismiss the Parliament so we're still
having ongoing discussions on that
particular issue but we agree both sides
agree that the reform should be
implemented for fair elections both
sides agree that the ban on the twice
elected prime minister should go both
sides agree that the moderate forces
should come together so they're in both
sides agree there should be a level
playing field in an end to motivated
litigation so there's a lot of agreement
apparent agreement on a lot of issues
while one or two still are outstanding
but right now the issue is when is the
implementation going to take place and
in which phase is this implementation
going to take place to complicate the
issue the ruling party has been saying
that nothing will change and that
they're not really negotiating with the
PPP they're just giving in our local
language deal that means a long rope so
this and they keep talking about how
they're going to impose emergency so
some people have cynically remarked that
the red mosque incident in Islamabad was
actually cooked up by elements of the
cabinet to provide a pretext for
emergency but their plan failed when the
presidency decided to take action
against the militants so you know we are
talking here about a country from which
many key al-qaeda suspects have been or
terrorists have been arrested like Abu
Zubaydah and carly shay from pindi and
ramzi bin al-shibh from Karachi so we
must remember that this is not just a
war for Pakistan heart and soul this is
something that will have far-reaching
ramifications on militant struggles
across our borders we and the PPP are
very determined to build peace in fact
we say the message of Islam is peace and
we want peace for our citizen side our
country we want an end to the attacks on
nato and afghan troops in nearby
afghanistan and we want an end to the
militants who try to hijack our foreign
policy by conducting attacks on the
indian parliament or on the other sides
and india so our world vision collides
rather dramatically with the world
vision of the extremists now Musharraf I
said he's for moderation and so we hope
that he can do something up front that
can facilitate moderate forces coming
together this president Chavez should
jettison of my son muslim lee has said
that maybe there will be in position of
emergency and assembly star movie
extended for one year if that happens
and what would be the position of your
party I believe my party would join with
all the other political parties to
protest any attempt to differ the
elections we would be what we have been
telling all the other political parties
we had an all parties conference in
London and we all agreed on certain
points for the holding of fair free and
impartial elections but whereas the
other political parties wanted to start
a movement straight away we said no we
have to wait we have to wait and see
whether either the elections are
postponed or we have to wait and see
whether the elections are rigged but to
start an agitation at this point might
tempt the rulers into imposing emergency
but I do think that if the doors of
election are shut on us an emergency is
imposed all the elections are rigged
then certainly the PPP with the other
political parties civil groups and NGOs
in Pakistan with pressure put pressure
like in Ukraine during the orange
revolution for the empowerment of our
people so you can see a street protest
of the type that sorry cently involving
the chief justice if I item bigger with
the participation of political parties
that's right I very much can see that
happening I would like to see it
happening because i don't think pakistan
needs anaki or civil strife or bloodshed
but both sides have a responsibility to
prevent that and the elections now give
general sheriff and the presidency as
well as the military establishment an
opportunity today
pakistan safely from one phase of
governance to another phase of
governance the spoilers are there after
all why would those who have politically
benefited from firing their shots from
the shoulders of the military want to
have fair elections which will see them
give up power and go into opposition so
I understand that there will be elements
like the ruling pml-q which will do
everything to scuttle a process of
reconciliation and resolution moving
Pakistan on to a moderate course but I
think it's important for General
Musharraf and the military establishment
to stay the course not to defer the
elections not to impose emergency and to
make sure that those elections are
credible and satisfy the public the
public are the important people we need
international observers otherwise
there's just going to be name-calling so
we need a third party that can certify
whether the elections are going to be
fair or not President Musharraf has been
criticized recently very severely in the
United States for not doing enough to
actually capture the al-qaeda suspects
hiding in Pakistan what do you think of
that do you think she is doing enough
well I know that as a Pakistani it
certainly hurts me very much when I see
that inevitably the trail of terrorists
leads back to my country if it's an
issue of the tube bomber we find that he
had visited Pakistan or if it's an issue
of John Reid the shoe bomber we find
that he had made a telephone call to
Pakistan if it's capturing the CEO of
al-qaeda harlot che we find that he was
captured in Pakistan's garrison city of
Rawalpindi so it bothers us Pakistanis
that our great nation should be
associated with such elements we don't
want to make our country hospitable to
such elements and my party severely
criticized the peace agreement that was
signed in 2006 with the tribe with the
Taliban elements in the tribal regions
of Pakistan and we feel that our tribal
areas were ceded to foreign elements to
Afghan Taliban and Adam and Chechen
militant
and fighters and now those groups
actually administer parts of our
territory and hold our people hostage
they dispense their own form of justice
they teach little twelve-year-old boys
to bed those they accuse of being spies
I mean the children should have pens in
the hand little children should have
schools to go to little children should
have dreams so why is it that it can
still continue and still in Pakistani
territory well this is a question that
General Musharraf and his regime must
answer while they have certainly
verbally expressed sentiment for the
right course of eliminating terrorism
and extremism in the country
unfortunately they have not been able to
assert the rule of law in the country my
government would move swiftly to assert
law and order in the tribal areas of
Pakistan to hunt down the al-qaeda
leaders were trying to take advantage of
the lack of law and order there to stop
the drug trade which is actually funding
and fuelling terrorism and to reform the
political madrasas who used the name
madrasa but I actually militant
headquarters using women and children as
human shields I'm a woman I'm a mother I
don't want to see the innocent women and
children of my country held up as human
shields as and killed as they were
during the red mask incident and I think
it's the duty of government to provide
the protection of the life and liberty
of its citizens so given that fact that
despite personal sheriff's marble
assurances that he's doing everything it
is still continuing in fact increasing
can you blame the Americans if they said
they would actually intervene with our
Pakistani permission well I can
understand that why they say that
because they feel that Islamabad is
failed to stop the terrorists and that's
why they would like to move in but I
would really urge against that I believe
that the violation of Pakistan's
sovereignty through unauthorized
military action will have very adverse
consequences when under attack
all pakistanis will forget their
differences and they will all unite so
any unauthorized action would fit the
nato against all the people of Pakistan
and I don't think that's advisable but I
think what it is advisable is to have a
close working relationship and certainly
when the PPP is elected to power we
intend to restore low in order to our
tribal areas and prevent the militants
from attacking an 80 so we intend to
take away the causes that can today
threaten air strikes against Pakistan
and we also intend to work very closely
with NATO and with the United States and
other countries to eliminate terrorism
to help us also in our tribal areas to
eliminate through intelligence sharing
and other means of cooperation Pakistan
has always softness strategic depth in
Afghanistan as a part of its security
policy do you think that policy has led
to this alliance defector linesman
Pakistani ISI and Taliban can you change
that well I certainly hope I can change
it I believe that the policy of
strategic depth has backfired and in
fact it was in 1998 that I stood up in
the parliament of Pakistan and I said
that the policy of strategic depth is
turning into one of strategic threat for
Pakistan and the passage of years have
shown to me that indeed such a policy is
leading to militancy suicide bombers
weaponization drug trade in Pakistan to
an increase in poverty and unemployment
as the priorities of the state shift and
these issues are neglected so I want an
end to that policy of strategic depth I
think of Hannah stan has traditionally
been viewed either as a buffer state or
as a forward policy state where there is
strategic depth and throughout history
different empires even the FR at the
British Empire or the Greeks when they
even came to that area have looked at
the issue in terms of strategic depth or
buffer state and I think for us it's
much better
have an Afghanistan that is peaceful
that allows us to trade with it that has
good relations with all its neighbors
and I think it's very promising that
Afghanistan has joined the south asian
association of regional countries and I
think for India Pakistan Afghanistan and
the other countries of South this is
where we should concentrate we should
try to create the economic
interdependencies that allowed Europe to
emerge from the ravages of two world
wars and build a common market that has
given unprecedented growth and an
increase in the standard of living of
ordinary Europeans I mean in the 50s
people were all on rations and now
they're spoiled for choice another issue
where I think you mentioned India
Kashmir seems to have been diffused a
little bit and do you see any prospect
that if you return to Pakistan as Prime
Minister you would have a different
approach than what has been tried by
mosharraf no I think we should have did
the right thing and following the spirit
of the simla agreement which my father
had signed with Prime Minister Indira
Gandhi and that the spirit of the
Declaration Islamabad declaration
wherein rajiv gandhi and i had had
decided to work for peaceful relations
certainly the fighting over Cargill and
the 1 million men who faced each other
eyeball to eyeball after the Indian
Parliament attack drove home the
dramatic consequences of a conflict
between India and Pakistan who are both
nuclear-capable States I don't think we
can afford this I think we shall do the
right thing we've been very critical of
him and he's done the wrong thing but
visibly the policy with India or visibly
the policy with women's rights visibly
restoring women's seat in parliament
well we supported those measures because
we don't believe in being totally
rejectionist or being totally accepting
we believe in dealing with issue by
issue so yes we would continue the
process of dialogue with India and not
only that I hope that in the 60th year
of our anniversary both countries are
turning 60 in a few days time
I hope that we can come and build a
peace treaty that will now enable our
people to turn their backs on an unhappy
past and look to a brighter future
Kashmir is an issue between us it is a
dispute but then you know India has a
dispute with China over the border but
they don't go to war with each other so
we need to learn that we can have
differing opinions without actually
allowing them to transform themselves
into conflict bloodshed terrorism
militants year war when you were Prime
Minister how much were you aware of a
queue Khan's nuclear sort of arms sales
activities I was not at all aware of his
nuclear arms sale opportunities in fact
its prime minister Pakistan my
government gave birth to the benzene
nuclear doctrine under this nuclear
doctrine Pakistan would not export
nuclear technology that was a cardinal
principle of the doctrine and we would
not put together the components of a
weapon unless our security was
threatened and that we were not a shape
and mold uranium into nuclear parts so
it was a policy that was bipartisan it
came through with consultations with the
presidency and the Armed Forces so it
was accepted by all as part of the
national interest and to my knowledge it
held until India detonated its nuclear
devices and then Prime Minister Nawaz
Sharif in retaliation detonated in
Pakistan so it was quite a shock that I
learned that the no export and nuclear
technology had been violated and then I
would not have believed it uncle AQ Khan
came on television and confessed and now
the only question before us is that did
he fall on his sword to protect others
over the others also involved for that
by party called for a parliamentary
inquiry those Pakistan can't afford to
endanger its own nuclear system by
scientists who begin to smuggle and
proliferate weapons of mass destruction
when he was flying c-130 of Pakistani
Air Force to carry stuff so is it
possible that he was doing it alone well
this is the issue that we want to
out the inquiry because it's amazing to
think that he could have access to c-130
aircraft and go to North Korea and not
only go to North Korea but go to so many
other countries i remember in general
Sharon's regime there had been a
full-page advertisement taken out by the
Ministry of Commerce advertising the
sale of nuclear components and many of
us were shocked this is before I Kohan's
whole issue had been unearthed 'add so
it was actually very shocking and
particularly in this world in which we
live and you know to where terrorists
want to get their hands on weapons of
mass destruction the entire world
community including Pakistanis who live
in the Diaspora as well as all other
human beings could face devastating
consequences if mad people managed to
get Lee Ord my money so I really like to
find out more about how AQ Khan went
around doing this Musharraf has pardoned
him well that's one ended spectrum but
the other end of the spectrum is we must
make sure that something like this can
never happen again had I cannot engaged
in this kind of activities wouldn't have
been possible today for Pakistan to sign
a civilian nuclear agreement with the
United States as India has done it's a
difficult call it's a difficult call I
think that your India is a larger market
and India's five times larger than
Pakistan and certainly the post-cold war
many academics had predicted that the
world the Western world would start
coming closer to India so it's difficult
to call but certainly Pakistanis are
disappointed that we weren't offered the
same civil nuclear agreement I hope that
at some stage we are able to be offered
such a civil nuclear cooperation but I
also want to take my generation away
from the earlier generations view of tit
for tat with India I mean we can't keep
competing with the Joneses we have to
identify our own core interests we need
to pursue our core in
not seek to so overextend ourselves that
we begin to collapse from within and I
think that's what the policy of
strategic depth has done its threatening
Pakistan from within and today if I
risked my life to go back to my country
I do it because I see the threat within
and I want to try and help my people and
help my country of our disaster the last
question if General Musharraf does not
doff his military uniform would you
still go back to Pakistan before the end
of the year yes I will go back to
Pakistan wetherill Musharraf takes his
uniform off or not I will go back to
Pakistan this year irrespective of
whether we have an agreement with
General Musharraf or not but I hope the
General Musharraf will review in light
of the circumstances in Pakistan after
the restoration of the Chief Justice of
Pakistan his decision to seek reelection
in uniform from the present assemblies
thank you very much mrs. go to thank you
thank you very much